-Our next guest is a Pulitze
Prize-winning journalist
and associate editor
of "The Washington Post."
His best-selling book "Rage"
is on sale now.
Please welcome to the show
Bob Woodward.
How are you, Bob?
-Well. Thank you.
-Thank you for being here.
The President had multiple
reactions to your book.
Based on the fact that he said
he read it in one night,
how did you react to what
we think we all know
is a very obvious lie?
-Well, maybe he took the
Evelyn Wood speed reading clas
in the 1970s.
-Yeah, that probably --
So, you know...
But he has had
varied reactions.
He initially said it was
a political hit job.
And then he said he read it,
found it boring,
"But he said some great things
in it," he said.
And then one of the Fox News
anchors actually asked him
the key question --
"Is it accurate?"
And he said,
"It's okay, it's fine."
-Which I think is about as
high a praise
as he's going to give
to a book about him,
certainly written by anyon
other than a close friend.
One of the things you asked him,
of course, in the book,
is, "Are you worried about
contracting coronavirus
because of the way
you are operating
through this pandemic?"
How do you reflect back on tha
in a week
where he very clearly
did contract it?
-Well, he just said,
and it was almost mystical
and we played the tape of it
on television where he said,
"No, I don't think
I'm going to get it."
And I said, "Why?"
And he said,
"I just don't think
I'm going to get it.
I'm not going to get it."
And it was said with the kin
of confidence
that obviously has
been not borne out
now that he has it.
But it's -- I mean, what I -
I went back and looked
at when we started releasing
those audios,
and you ran one of them
about three weeks ago
in which he said
back in February
that it's deadly,
it's deadlier than the flu
and it can be transmitted by
people who don't show symptoms
but very much emphasized
with numbers
that it's more deadly
than the flu.
And now today he says, no,
the flu is more deadly
than the virus.
Of course, the numbers totally
contradict that.
And he put that up on Facebook
and tweeted it.
And it's interesting, mayb
we've made some progress.
Facebook made him take it down
because it's not true.
And in the case of Twitter
they -- I guess they don't
take things down,
but they just say it's false
So you can read it
and see that
the Twitter executives
label it false.
-You know, that, I think,
speaks to one of the trickiest
parts of you writing
a portrait of a president.
You mention that he obviousl
tells us all it's the flu.
He tells you privately
it's worse than the flu.
Now he gets it, and he's back to
telling people the flu is worse.
How do you paint a portrait of
somebody that holds, you know,
any given position for no longer
than a minute or two?
-Well, he does hold
some positions.
For ten months his denial
about the significance of th
virus is very evident.
Back in January
they laid it out for him,
told him it will be the
biggest national security threat
to your presidency.
Told him exactly why
and that the Deputy National
Security Advisor
had impeccable medical sources
in Hong Kong and China.
And he ignored that.
He did tell me in February
oh, yeah, that's when he sai
it's going to be worse.
And then he always said,
"I'm playing it down.
I'm playing it down."
It was not until May
that I learned that --
about the January meeting,
and so when it's in the book
it's a whole picture of hi
avoiding his responsibilit
to protect the public.
One of the first interview
I did with him,
I asked the question, "What'
the job of the President?"
And he said,
"To protect the people."
He failed catastrophically
on that front.
President's other job
is to tell the truth.
He failed to tell the truth.
And what he did in this,
I believe,
because the record is
so clear and mind-numbing,
will go down in history as
one of the great
presidential mistakes
of all time.
-You -- I'm sorry to have to
ask this question,
but a friend of mine
wanted me to ask.
-No, don't.
-You won a Pulitzer.
Does that --
Do you get any money with that
-[ Laughs ]
I saw earlier you were --
-I mean, is it just an award
or is there a little bit
of, you know...
-The Pulitzer Prize
for Watergate was
the Public Service Pulitzer,
which is a gold medal
that they give the newspaper
"The Washington Post."
So there's -- in some case
that you can't get into,
is the gold medal.
And so I didn't get
a share of it.
It rightly went to
the newspaper.
Carl Bernstein and I did
some of the work,
but we had a great editor,
Ben Bradlee,
and Katharine Graham,
the owner of the paper,
a very wise lady.
Can I tell a story about her
-Please.
-And she --
After Nixon resigned,
and, oh, it was about just
a few weeks afterwards,
she wrote Carl and myself
a letter,
but she wrote it
on yellow legal pad.
She had more stationery than any
thousand people in Washington.
But this, I think it was
a spontaneous, honest reaction
And she said,
"Dear Carl and Bob,
you did some of the stories.
Nixon's resigned.
Now, don't start thinking
too highly of yourselves,
and let me give you some advice.
And the advice is,
beware the demon pomposity."
And, wow,
what an important lesson
for me, for Carl,
people in the media business
people in politics,
people in business,
even people in show business
Pomposity is a demon,
and it gets in the way
of lots of people
doing good work
or their best work.
-If you write a third book
it would also make
one heck of a title
for our President.
Thank you so much.
-The demon pomposity lives
-Yes, absolutely.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations on the book